a man four of whom I've been a fan for
quite some time
CBS's nine JKL is a new series that airs
Mondays at 8:30 p.m. Eastern starring in
part this man Elliot Gould good to see
you sir great and Linda Lavin and mark
Feuerstein and David Walton who was here
with faeries great a couple of weeks ago
Liesl appear oh yeah it's a whole new
family it's about the family all a new
family and we'll get to that in a in a
short moment here have you what's the
biggest sporting event you've ever been
to Elliot that comes to mind was the
seventh game of the championship series
when Willis Reed limped onto the floor
and hit Madison Square Garden for Lakers
that night that was the first
championship for the Knickerbocker what
was it like being in the garden in those
days very very very exciting when we
came on the floor did you think because
the in retrospect when Elliott when when
Willis Reed came on the floor it's it's
been told that's when everybody knew it
was over
the game was over no it wasn't ever over
a bay he participated we had to win it
you know and we had Walt Frazier and
Bill Bradley was a friend of mine he was
number 24 mm-hmm yeah and Dave
DeBusschere was 22 Phil Jackson okay
Phil was good yeah but I know Dave
DeBusschere it's hard to mention as
players Dave DeBusschere and Phil
Jackson and Phil won't mind it I mean
Dave DeBusschere once he was traded from
Detroit to the Knickerbockers for Howard
Koh my vests and Walt Bellamy we became
champions for the first time man
you know I just and and and the Knicks
have been trying trying Dodgers were
when when I was a little baby and
growing up you I heard you mention about
Yankee Dodger World Series 1955 was like
more than a Bar Mitzvah for Johnny
Padres in Sandy Amer oh sure they
finally broke through against those Damn
Yankees yeah that was a great show damn
Yankee ji to have heart yeah he was from
that show was from that and so you grew
up going Abbott's field essentially my
mother would take me I
Tibbits feel my mommy and daddy would
take me to Ebbets Field it was about a
year and a half
Dolph camilli played first I'm told but
they told me every time something
happened we were in the toilet cuz I
always had to pee
that's funny so did you you recall
Jackie Robinson playing or oh yeah the
first game he ever played in Ebbets
Field was in the course of the subway
series with the Yankees in 1947 and my
parents took me there and I thought this
is gonna this is April of 1947 about to
be Jackie's first season and it was in
Ebbets Field and I thought this is gonna
be a blue sky at gorgeous day was gray
overcast and cold but I got to see
Jackie so you were at Jackie Robinson's
first game Willis Reed coming onto the
floor in game 7 yeah that's incredible I
mean that right there in life is like
that
I know it's everybody has relative
memories like this everybody I know and
that's the beauty of that's the beauty
of sports somebody asked me who my
favorite philosophers were and I said
the birds and the bees Larry Bird he's
great Larry Bird was great Bob wolf was
a manager he just passed away he passed
away several years ago during the course
of a Monday night game Oh different Bob
wolf was a great guy okay so his manager
so you met you met you met Larry Bird
through or through you know no I would
go into the locker room he was playing
at the Forum and and the night before I
had scored I'm like a lot of points
against the doctor against Julius and I
said somebody said that if he didn't dr.
J didn't start playing defense Larry
would would score a hundred points
against him and I said was that true and
he said no but I would have scored a
hundred points l lead gold here on the
Rich Eisen show and so tell me the story
of his the 76 Oscars 1976 is that great
yes well Johnny or the great a French
actress and I were there to give away
the award for at
and of course a Monday night the NCAA
finals Indiana and Michigan and that's
was really happening and the Oscars with
all due respect to my business and all
of that that's a popularity contest but
with NCAA finals that was great and and
so just before I walked out I heard the
final of the game was Indiana 86
Michigan 68 so when Isabelle said the
winner is I said Indiana 86 in Michigan
68 and the only reason I could remember
it is graphically it was a perfect
reversal palindrome yeah right and so so
we did it and a Verna fields who was the
editor of Jaws who won it said that she
soiled her pants because it was I broke
the mold you know so did did it how did
you hear about it on the radio
I mean well there we have a crew people
real people who work this we can't be on
the air without the unions and the crews
I'm a total unionist so yeah that's it
was there was going on Bobby Knight told
me personally that other than winning
the game itself that was the greatest
thing to happen for people in Middle
America yeah that we stayed real people
you know so Bob Knight
so you when did you meet Bob Knight oh
he asked me through ABC if I would be
his the special correspondent for his
Olympic team and that's when I met a few
of the players who made it which ones
well I didn't you know what a casa is I
didn't want to be a hostage means you
don't want it you don't to keep taking
you don't give me yet then not too much
so I mean I had heard of Michael Jordan
and so I left him out but later on I
played him I'll tell you my Michael
Jordan but I met Wayman Tisdale I met
Chris Mullins I met Patrick Ewing and I
thought let me meet the least of the
guys RIS Alford was Bobby Knights kid at
Indiana he was he ran the team well
Steve Alford now he's now the coach at
UCLA I know
yeah yeah and you're sitting behind the
desk and have a great career know that
and so you know so they invited me to
Bloomington and that was a day of the
last cuts Charles Barkley had just been
cut when I showed up and it was great
Bobby Knight and our are our friends I
would never choke a kid but he's a great
coach our deli code tell me or Jordan
story then well I was asked to play him
a horse around the world and one on one
for abused and homeless children for
cameras it people have showed it to me
you know I'm not very good with
technology and so we played a horse hmm
and I could shoot and especially back
then I could shoot with two hands and
Michael doesn't shoot with two hands and
so I said I'm gonna start us off with an
old-fashioned traditional fundamental is
a very good keyword two-handed set shot
like Red Auerbach taught me and I could
hit a swish and Michael didn't shoot so
right away he's got a letter
he's behind and I could shoot Michael
went to half-court lined up closed his
eyes stuck his tongue out and hit two
shots and I could barely reach it from
there you know I have to he've it but
now I SiC okay Michael fly for me so he
put the ball on the floor went up over
the cylinder did a 360 and slammed it
and I have to give the impression that
I'm gonna try to do that then we played
around the world and and Michael didn't
want every game and so you beat Michael
Jordan Michael Jordan lost to me mm-hmm
and around the world I'm coming around I
miss a shot nobody's perfect Michael
doesn't close it out I come all the way
back around and I said to dick Van
Patten who was running it for for you
know for for management yeah I said now
I said in the playground in the
schoolyard where I learned the game if
you come all the way back around you got
a sink three foul shots you close out
the game and he said just she
one and I did so Michael didn't win
around the world and I said it made
sense that a Jew would beat Michael
Jordan around the world you know we are
always trying we're always going around
the world giving you a headache now no
it's fantastic I just didn't think that
there would be an Eliot Gould Michael
Jordan story would dick Van Patten
thrown in but that's why I exist in this
world to take your stories like that oh
it's fantastic
before I let you go Eliot nine JKL what
do I mean here you are I mean you've
done friends you've done so much before
what makes this one special for you I'm
also a grandfather and it okay and and
the family Dana Klein was married to a
mark Feuerstein who's one of the sons
and you had David Walton on yes I mean
it's a it's a very funny family and
what's but I think family is always
special no matter what culture were in
and this is a very American ethnic New
York family and Dana Klein is the
showrunner and she and Mark create the
show and I think it's really great and
it's great fun and I'm so privileged and
grateful to be a part of it and it's on
again 8:30 s p.m. on CBS every single
Monday Elliott this has been thrilling
this is great I have a feeling we have
if your sports stories are the iceberg
we've just seen there I tell you I was
very friendly with two people that you
would want to know but we may want to
defer that one that one was John Wooden
who was I was his friend for his last
three years and when we met he told me
he had been an English teacher in
Indiana and that's the most important
word in the English language is love and
the second most important word is
balance and Groucho Marx with whom I was
very very friendly and when I changed a
light bulb over his bed he gave me my
greatest review he said that's the best
acting I've ever seen
Elliott come back any time I'd love to
thank fantastic for more Rich Eisen show
tuned to audience channel 239
be or download the Rich Eisen show app